c'était il y a trois mois jour pour jour
l'armée russe envahissent l ukraine
certains prédisaient une guerre éclair
la chute du pouvoir incarner part
volodymyr zelensky avant de débattre sur
tout ce que ce conflit a bouleversé dans
l'équilibré géostratégique ans se
remémore les grandes dates avec flora
sauvage 5 heures du matin le 24 février
vladimir poutine annoncent l'envoi de
troupes en ukraine pour une opération
spéciale
l'objectif démilitarisé et des nazifié
le pays qui souhaite adhérer à l'otan
pendant que la stupeur gagne le monde
les troupes russes pénètre en ukraine
depuis le nord l'est et la crimée dans
la journée les forces russes prennent le
contrôle de la centrale de tchernobyl le
maître du kremlin brandi la menace
nucléaire alors que les principales
villes du pays se réveille sous le feu
des explosions les exceed antho inflige
des sanctions économiques à la russie
l'union européenne annonce la livraison
d'armes à l'ukraine le 2 mars la ville
de kars on est prise par les troupes
russes une semaine après le début de
l'invasion le 9 mars le port stratégique
de mario paul et celui de lourds
bombardements qui touche un hôpital pour
enfants
les images font le tour du monde mais ce
qui va faire basculer l'opinion
internationale ce sont les images du
village martyr de boudhha à quelques
kilomètres de la capitale où plus de
mille corps de civils seront retrouvés
dans des fosses communes après le départ
de l'armée russe sur le terrain la
résistance s'organise le 14 avril les
ukrainiens affirment avoir frappé un
navire amiral de la flotte russe qui
coule dans la mer noire le 4 mai la
commission européenne adopte un sixième
paquet de sanctions à l'encontre de la
russie le congrès américain débloque 40
milliards de dollars pour soutenir
l'effort de guerre ukrainien depuis le
début de la guerre 6 millions
d'ukrainiens ont fui leur pays s'il
n'existe aucun bilan global des victimes
civiles du conflit les enquêteurs
ukrainiens affirment avoir identifié
plus de 8000 cas présumés de crimes de
guerre les conséquences de ce conflit en
ukraine voilà le thème de notre débat
les conséquences géostratégiques qui
sont majeurs
je vous présente mes invités et rina
mitri chine bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'inalco
l'institut national des langues et
civilisations orientales responsable des
études ukrainienne christian la
guerrière bonsoir vous êtes essayiste
chroniqueur internationale au point
pierre haski bonsoir chroniqueur
géopolitique à france inter et lætitia
cru pas éditorialiste politique est
resté à mes côtés je vous propose pour
ouvrir ce débat de réagir sur ce bilan
fait hier par le président ukrainien
trois mois de frappes aériennes russes
on écoute aux trusts au total depuis le
24 février l'armée russe a effectué 1474
frappes de missiles en ukraine avec 2275
missiles différentiel la grande majorité
contre des infrastructures civiles
cette zone est pour nous plus de 3000
frappes aériennes en moins de trois mois
d'avions et d'hélicoptères russes quel
autre pays a connu une telle intensité
de frappe
irene à dmitry chine est ce que vous
pouvez nous nous décrire ce que le
donbass
vit en ce moment ce que les habitants du
dombass vivent depuis depuis plusieurs
jours ce déluge de feu dont on parle il
n'y a pas que dans le bas cenon qui a
évoqué il ya le sud de l'ukraine il ya
tout ce qui s'est passé au début de la
guerre aucun surtout de pays hors acp
qui les frappe qui ont touché les
régions occidentale de l'ukraine qui
compensait été protégés et qu'ils
n'étaient qui n'était pas atteignable
dans l'immédiat c'est tout ce mois
l'horreur c'est la vie des millions de
personnes qui est bouleversée et qui en
suspend le temps de cette guerre avec à
la fois ceux qui perdent leurs proches
dans dans les bordeaux ou tout
simplement dans d'alarmé ce sont des
défenseurs du pays et tous ceux qui ont
dû partir se séparer et très dispersées
à travers le monde ce jeu je parlais des
vraiment de ce qui se passe qui sur ma
carrière depuis la stratégie russe
depuis depuis quelques jours c'est quoi
cette stratégie elle semble avoir changé
bon il ya les points manifeste on est
passé du blitzkrieg tilly à trois mois
au début à une guerre beaucoup plus
lente et resserrée mais en dégarnissant
la zone de quartier et la zone de mario
falk était définitivement prise les
russes ont fait une réaffectation de
leurs ressources et de leurs effectifs
sur la zone qu'ils ont définis comme
prioritaires maintenant c'est à dire si
vous regardez la carte en bande droite
10 ou à donetsk et vous avez là un petit
triangle de renfoncement dans lequel se
trouvent deux villes sur lesquels il
exerce un véritable écrasement
d'artillerie et il faut parler de l'art
thierry
ces deux villes ce sont ces verrous
donetsk est licite chance qu donc pour
les russes il est très important
d'encercler civile puis de les écraser
comme ils l'ont fait à marioupol et pour
les ukrainiens il est très important
d'arrêter les russes avant qu'ils
n'arrivent au stade de l'encerclement
parce qu'ils ont très bien compris cela
au début les ukrainiens ont été très
habile à développer une guerre des
villes parce que la russie avait la
supériorité tél en matière de plan dès
qu'ils occupaient l'espace une bataille
rase campagne eut été meurtrière est
absolument terrible pour les ukrainiens
le sort des armes auraient été
totalement défavorables à l'ukraine donc
l'ukraine a développé une guerre des
villes mais la russie s'est fait avoir
si j'ose dire par cette stratégie est
elle a perdu la russie maintenant on est
dans la deuxième phase où les russes
passe maître de cette guerre des villes
mais d'une façon qui échappe à toutes
les lois de la guerre classique
c'est-à-dire un bombardement un
écrasement d'artillerie dont je rappelle
que je rappelle que staline disait que
c'était la mère de toutes les batailles
d'artillerie et la russie a une super u
tin d'artillerie c'est la raison pour
laquelle les occidentaux aide les
ukrainiens en artillerie regardez le cas
de la france avec cette douzaine de
canon caesar qu'on va envoyer aux
ukrainiens
en un cheminement il faut jamais oublier
non plus que l'ukraine est un pays très
étirées comme tout arrive par la région
de le vif il ya 1300 kilomètres pour
arriver jusqu'à ces vélos donetsk c'est
énorme comme distance donc les russes
jouent de tout cela pour essayer de
passer à une stratégie de pilonnages
alors c'était vraiment la question que
j'allais vous posez pierre haski la
logistique parce que c'est que c'est une
dimension qui est très importante
finalement cette phase de la guerre elle
est peut-être plus favorable aux russes
parce que la logistique et plus facile à
mettre en place que quand il essayait de
faire tomber kiev oui on l'a vu au début
de la guerre lorsque les rues sur des
problèmes d'approvisionnement d'essence
nos rations alimentaires
ça a été un cauchemar de logistique qui
a surpris tout le monde parce qu'on
pensait que qu'une guerre de cette
ampleur était mieux préparé que l'armée
russe serait un peu plus au point que ça
mais là évidemment ces problèmes la
sphère des longues lignes
d'approvisionnement très loin des bases
arrière etc ont disparu puisque on est à
proximité des deux républiques
séparatistes
du donbass est pas très loin de la
russie elle même avec des des lignes de
d'approvisionnement qui sont beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus commode ça n'empêche
que la russie a aujourd'hui des
problèmes de d'approvisionnement un
certain type de missile parce qu'elle en
a beaucoup tiré qu'elle n'a plus de
stock et que
conducteur aussi on avait évoqué sa
une par une et mûri mondial mais quand
on fait la guerre on a besoin de semi
conducteurs est tout à fait ça c'est
aussi l'impact des sanctions qui fait
que qu'elle ne peut plus approvisionné à
certaines sources mais effectivement le
terrain est plus favorable aujourd'hui à
l'armée russe la géographie à proximité
de la russie lui également plus
favorable et on est dans un
configuration qui fait plutôt penser à
la première guerre mondiale maintenant
c'est à dire
ddd ligne des tranchées vous avez un
jaurès français le bureau qui vient de
faire un film qui est sorti en salle et
qui a acquis pendant sept ans à filmer
chaque année les soldats ukrainien dans
les tranchées et il est allé là bas
parce que il avait le souvenir de son
grand des récits de son grand père de la
première guerre mondiale et il voulait
il voulait revivre ce que ce que son
grand-père avait vécu et c'est les
tranchées du donbass c'est la première
guerre mondiale et une guerre qu'on n'a
pas vu en europe depuis depuis cette
époque alors l'une des images une
désinformation deux de ces dernières 48
heures c'est la condamnation d'un
premier criminel de guerre hier verdict
prison à vie pour ce soldat russe âgé de
21 ans laetitia oui c'était un procès
historique pourquoi parce que c'est le
premier et on sait que l'ukraine a
ouvert déjà plus de 12000 enquête pour
crimes de guerre d'ailleurs il ya un
autre procès qui s'est ouvert dans la
foulée concernant deux soldats de
soldats russes alors ce sera le procès
historique et ce jeune homme de 21 ans
est pour la communauté occidentale
international l'incarnation du mal voilà
est le symbole de cette justice est
clair qui est là pour laver
les violences les crimes faits perpétrés
par l'envahisseur russe mais je me suis
interrogée alors je vous livre là une
réflexion ce n'est absolument pas une
affirmation parce que je voudrais qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble sur cette naïveté
finalement de la communauté occidentale
à faire de ce jeune homme de 21 ans
encore une fois cette incarnation du mal
russe voyez-vous parce qu'il me semble
que c'est l'incarnation surtout de la
guerre totalement insensé et de
l'instrumentalisation de la jeunesse à
des fins de dessin géopolitique
totalement irrationnel et donc je crois
qu'on se trompe un peu voyez vous en en
faisant un procès exemplaire pour nous
occidentaux à regarder ce jeune russe
qui finalement paye pour tous les autres
et pour tous les autres criminels je
crois que c'est un peu naïf et c'est
aussi naïf car nous sommes d'une
certaine façon aussi instrumentalisé par
les deux propagande la propagande bien
sûr ukrainienne qui ont fait encore une
fois un symbole et puis aussi les russes
qui vont tenter de se le réapproprier
donc je veux juste avec cette image que
finalement les médias français ont eu
tendance à lire de la même façon façon
un peu unanime peut-être mettre un tout
petit peu plus d'aspérités et de recul
et se dire que finalement ce jeune homme
de cyber et de 21 ans au crâne rasé qui
a fait appel un qui est à baisser les
yeux pendant tout le verdict mais qu' un
parmi d'autres irina maîtrisé quel
symbole vous voyez vous la justice
ukrainienne qui veut montrer qu'elle
fonctionne il veut montrer qu'elle
fonctionne elle veut aussi montrer à
tous ceux qui sont aujourd'hui sur le
champ de bataille où sur le territoire
occupé que ils seront rattrapés et que
la justice viendra les chercher je pense
pas que ce garçon incarne le mal absolu
ya quand même des crimes beaucoup plus
terribles qui ont été perpétrés le
la dans le cas de ce garçon les choses
sont limpides c'est à dire qu'ils les
choses ont été établis il a été attrapé
si j'ose dire donc donc on a pu faire
dans cette simplicité un procès rapide
il y a des cas je pense des violences
notamment des viols des tortures on a
identifié par exemple ceux qui ont tué
c'est ce couple de
demers en fait la mère d'une d'une ville
de meaux jean qui a été tué et torturé
avec son fils son mari donc ces gens là
ceux identifiés est ce qu'ils seront un
jour traduit devant la justice parce que
ils ne sont tout simplement pas là ils
sont ils sont sur le champ de bataille
seront sans doute tu es donc il y aura
peut-être aussi une tentative de la
russie de d'effacer les crimes donc
c'est le premier procès ce ne sera pas
le plus grave et le plus important et
vous l'avez dit laeticia 12000 enquête
pour crimes de guerre ouverte selon le
parquet ukrainien et christian mas
gayant est ce que ces images ces procès
peuvent avoir un impact même faible même
indirecte sur les soldats russes sur
leur grade et éventuellement et je pense
que la manoeuvre de l'ukraine vise aussi
beaucoup la russie green moscou seraient
d'accord il ya trois batailles la
bataille militaire a parlé la bataille
de communication emporté de très très
loin pas malade et mercedes qui et puis
la bataille judiciaire qui commence à
peine il va y avoir derrière le procès
de la justice nationale souveraine de la
république d'ukraine mais avoir un
énorme problème de droit international
d'ailleurs l'ukraine a commencé à
proposer à la cour pénale internationale
de réfléchir sur la notion de crime
d'agression qu'on appelait autrefois
crimes contre la paix tout cela c'est
très complexe ans donc on va pas se
lancer là dedans mais ça signifie qu'un
état qui viole la souveraineté d'un
autre sans raison autre que un pur
objectifs nationalistes sans avoir été
lui-même menacé dans ses intérêts ou
dans ses frontières
rentrer dans un cas d'agression qui peut
lui valoir une condamnation ce n'est pas
un droit abouti encore mais c'est un
droit en gestation et l'ukraine a
commencé cette procédure là donc oui
derrière tout cela il ya l'idée qui est
très simple nous les ukrainiens
nous jugeons les criminels de guerre pas
les prisonniers et on envoie un message
aux russes attention si vous confondez
prisonniers de guerre couverts par la
convention de genève et criminels de
guerre nous serons vigilants et nous
ferons condamner devant le monde entier
cette partie judiciaire vaal contestable
le mans s'ouvrir pour le futur et la
l'ukraine a pris littéralement les
devants et respect oui mais je partage
vos réserves sur ce qui s'est passé je
suis pas sûr que c'était une bonne idée
au milieu d'eux du conflit de faire ce
procès je pense que la justice des
vainqueurs
en l'occurrence ceux qui ont capturé ce
soldat
n'est n'est jamais très bonne
conseillère et je trouve que
l'ukraine aurait plus à gagner à
organiser la suite c'est à dire un
tribunal spécial un tribunal
international
éventuellement la cour pénale mais ça
j'y crois à moitié parce que la cour
pénale
a un lien avec le conseil de sécurité et
que la russie sera en mesure de le
bloquer mais en tout cas de de faire un
travail qu'ils soient irréprochables la
justice en temps de guerre ne peut pas
être irréprochable elle et elle elle va
le travail de ce fait dans un climat
d'émotion et de et de passion qui n'est
pas
approprié et je trouve que le gain qu'a
pu faire l'ukraine en
montrant que c'était un état de droit
qui dit juger un criminel même s'il ya
des enquêteurs internationaux sur place
oui mais les uns critères internationaux
qui sont présents ils recueillent des
données pour la suite pour nous pour
pour le moment où on pourra faire
véritablement un travail comme ça a pu
être fait par exemple pour l'ex
yougoslavie où il ya eu un très un
tribunal pénal international dédié aux
crimes de l'ex yougoslavie en a eu 1 sur
le sur le rwanda les ces procès sont des
moments importants
regardez le procès du rebberg
historique et qui est sans doute la
référence absolue c'est celui dans
lequel le les crimes de génocide et de
et de crimes contre l'humanité ont été
codifiées pour la première fois vous
avez ce livre de philippe sand qui est
un avocat qui lui milite aujourd'hui
pour la création d'un tribunal spécial
pour les crimes en ukraine
qui raconte la genèse de ces deux de ces
deux nouvelles dimensions qu'on était le
crime contre l'humanité et le crime de
génocide etc nuremberg qui a permis de
les introduire dans le code pénal ou
dans le le corpus me mondiale je pense
qu'on en ukraine aurait tout à gagner à
faire les choses
d'une manière irréprochable de ce point
je voudrais qu'on parle maintenant
d'aider des conséquences géopolitiques
de cette guerre qui semble incarner ans
et c'est vraiment une nouvelle ère qui
est en train de s'ouvrir devant donohue
toutes les certain nombre de certitudes
qui sont balayées moi je le crois on a
parlé beaucoup de démondialisation de
des modernisations la russie dans le
rôle de la puissance archaïque
reconnaître que ja ja du crédit à cette
à cette thèse on a parlé de des
démocratisations pour empêcher l'ukraine
d'accéder à la halle à la démocratie
mais je crois qu'il ya plusieurs effets
politiques géopolitiques tout à fait
essentiel d'abord c'est la première fois
pensé au fond à la crise des fusées de
de cuba au début des années 60 que le
nucléaire sert à utiliser à ce degré là
le conventionnel d'habitude pendant la
guerre froide le nucléaire est tellement
effrayant qu'il empêche certains
développements en tout cas même indirect
affrontements entre les états unis et la
russie là la russie attaque de façon
coloniale son propre concept impérial
donc un territoire qu'elle considère
comme lui étant assujetti par nature et
par l'histoire mais tout de même
l'implication des etats-unis fait que le
degré de tension ne cesse de monter là
aujourd'hui en fait les trois mois moi
ce qui me frappe en trois mois c'est qu'
à aucun degré d'arrêt le point
paroxystique n'est toujours pas atteint
on est encore dans l'escaladé et si on
veut y arriver un peu plus clairement il
faut encore accentuée l'escaladent par
les livraisons d'armes et c'est parce
que la russie comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure est en train de remporter un
petit peu quelques victoires ça veut pas
dire qu'elle a vaincue elle a perdu 7
semblant d ce qui est gigantesque
c'est à la fois là le parc blindé de la
france de l'allemagne et du royaume-uni
700 blindés la russie a reçu une
correction mais elle a le moyen de faire
durer cette guerre dont tout le monde
oublie qu'elle date de 2014
donc si elle a duré si longtemps elle
peut encore durer très longtemps ça
c'est le calcul des russes et enfin il
ya une conséquences terribles pour
l'europe c'est que on a cru que les
états unis se retiraient d'europe ici
réinvesti smith et réinvestissent samper
dans leur obsession chinoise c'est à
dire pour envoyer là aussi une leçon à
la chine en disant 'vous voyez vous
croyez qu'on s'est retiré à cause de
l'histoire de kaboul on est bel et bien
là il y aura en de louey 5 passes à
l'est le centre de gravité de leur en
parler ça ça va influer beaucoup sur la
france veut vous redonner la parole aux
uns et aux autres l'assumer sur l'europe
je voudrais qu'on écoute
ce constat réalisé par qui par vladimir
poutine il affirme qu'en matière
d'hydrocarbures l'union européenne se
livrent un suicide économique c'est ya
quelques jours on écoute
le rejet des ressources énergétiques
russes signifie que systématiquement
dans une perspective à long terme
l'europe devient la région où le coût
des ressources énergétiques est le plus
élevé l'esp
commettre un tel autodafé intel suicide
économique c'est évidemment une affaire
intérieure des pays européens au tennis
qu'extra pierre haski au delà de ce que
dit lanières poutine ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en prononçant ces
mots suicide économique il il appuie
quand même sur un certain nombre de
lignes de fracture au sein de l'union
européenne qui n'apparaissent pas
forcément au grand jour qui sont pas les
plus médiatisés mais qui existent
d'abord
poutine a raison de dire que l'europe
comme celui-ci dans la mesure où elle
s'est livré pieds et poings liés à la
russie par sa dépendance au gaz c'est
quand même un vieux débat qui est
maintenant trancher sur north stream ii
le gazoduc avec l'allemagne sur le fait
que des pays l'autriche avait 100% de
son gaz qui venait de de russie c'est
insensé quand on y repense aujourd'hui
d'avoir dormi comme ça sur des
certitudes stratégique qui n'en étaient
pas et qui ignoraient tout les tous les
signaux maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
une c'est une affaire qui va
transformer l'europe pour deux raisons
la première c'est que elle a franchi un
cap dans dans sa conscience de la
nécessité de devenir une puissance ça
fait des décennies c'est un vieux débat
tous ceux qui suivent les affaires
européennes depuis
l'éternité savent que la france avait ce
discours sur une europe puissance une
europe puissante et elle parlé dans le
vide parce que l'europe n'avait pas
envie de devenir une puissance
aujourd'hui allié contre ate et il ya
cette prise de conscience le revers de
la médaille c'est que ça se fait avec
l'otan
lorsque il ne reste plus que quatre pays
de l'union européenne qui ne sont pas
membres de l'otan l'irlande l'autriche
chypre et malte oui quand la finlande
est là dedans la faveur de la cpi serait
temps et donc il ya une à une sur
imposition désormais entre la défense
européenne et l'alliance atlantique et
s'arrêter comme ça veut dire c'est à
dire plus de dépendance à la puissance
américaine pour le l'idée le concept
défendu par emmanuel macron de
souveraineté stratégique se heurte
aujourd'hui à la réalité de du fait que
les européens
ont repris confiance dans les états unis
et l'otan que macron décrivez comme un
état de mort cérébrale il ya seulement
deux ans est aujourd'hui au centre du
débat donc la donne a changé c'est des
choses qui vont avoir des conséquences
énormes parce que la défense européenne
ça sera le pilier européen de l'otan et
non plus une une autonomie à l'extérieur
donc ça c'est un deuxième chose est la
troisième celle équilibres internes à
l'intérieur de l'europe où on voit bien
que les pays du flanc est c'est à dire
ceux qui sont confrontés directement à
la menace russe les baltes les polonais
certain nombre de pays d'europe centrale
et les scandinaves où les pays nordiques
sont aujourd'hui les plus allants
politiquement les plus engagés dans le
soutien l'ukraine et que les les anciens
pilotes traditionnels que sont la france
et l'allemagne son talent a au contraire
l'objet de critiques de et d'accusations
de ne pas avoir compris assez vite ce
qui se passait alors justement il ya une
à dmitry chine qui j'aimerais savoir
comment le soutien de de la france est
perçue en ukraine et comment peut-être
aussi les tentatives d' emmanuel macron
de maintenir un lien avec vladimir
poutine sont sont évaluées sont jugées
mal mal à est très clair en un seul vous
oui parce que les ukrainiens envoie dans
ses tentatives une façon de faire la
paix sur le dos des ukrainiens c'est à
dire sur aux prix des concessions
territoriales etc et donc c'est en
quelque sorte une prime à l'agresseur à
celui qui a commis toutes ces atrocités
toutes ces souffrances responsable de
tant de destruction et tant de morts et
que maintenant il va tout simplement
prendre les big il a déjà obtenu et
répartir et ça s'est tellement
inacceptable donc l'ukraine aujourd'hui
je ne dis pas que ça changera pas ils
prennent aujourd'hui n'a pas de paix à
tout prix elle a besoin de victoires et
de justice 1 et ça veut dire par exemple
la proposition faite par emmanuel macron
parce qu on a bien compris que
[Musique]
une entrée de l'ukraine dans l'union
européenne ça prendra beaucoup de temps
plusieurs années donc à 7,7 cette idée
ce respect de l'espace intermédiaire qui
pourrait accueillir l'ukraine saxe a été
quoi quasiment au jeté ou en tout cas on
peut dire que l'accueil a été glaciale
alors peut-être ça a été mal expliqué
péter il n'a pas très bien compris ce
que ça voulait dire en tout cas ça a été
perçu en ukraine comme une façon de
retarder la la la la la marche de
l'ukraine de proposer quelque chose de
un ersatz n'était pas forcément la
volonté de maintenant ils vont
d'ailleurs
et puis l'expliqué mieux aussi parce que
derrière il ya quand même un cas qu'est
celui de la serbie du monténégro de la
république de macédoine et du nord de
l'albanie etc qui sont demandeuses qui
ont frappé à la porte et qui ont fait
une partie du parcours donc faire passer
l'ukraine par dessus tout ça ça n'est
pas possible non plus donc la
proposition de macron étaient étaient
fondées mais d'un point de vue comme l'a
dit peyras qui effectivement celui de
l'europe de l'ouest
or pour l'instant
l'indignation et l'émotion est beaucoup
plus du côté de l'europe de l'est et un
déplacement encore une fois du centre de
gravité de l'europe il ya surtout
quelque chose qui est apparu c'est que
l'europe qui était qu'avait pour
marqueurs dans le monde entier d'être la
zone de paix là où les pires
déflagration s'était produite et on
avait fait la paix là l'europe qui était
le flagship de la paix est devenue une
zone qui n'est plus frappés me
caractérise est marqué par la stabilité
et alors ça ça envoie un message au
reste du monde qui ne peut pas ne pas
être interprété comme un affaiblissement
et il va falloir prendre en compte cela
dans nos rapports par exemple avec des
pays africains ou du moyen-orient voyez
bien l'ambiguïté de pays comme l'algérie
le sénégal les pays du golfe qui se sont
montrés très bienveillant avec la russie
finalement bien à ce qui est la russie
peut-elle sortir de cette guerre autre
manque affaibli et isolé
alors
je pense qu'il faut toujours nuancé
cette question de l' isolement parce que
quand vous êtes vous avez la chine avec
vous est ce que vous êtes vraiment isolé
sur cette planète quand vous avez et qui
survient de le décrire un monde qui
estime que ce conflit c'est un résidu de
la guerre froide c'est un reste de
2de guerre européenne et que ça nous
concerne pas c'est quand même beaucoup
la conception qui a eu en afrique les
pays du golfe c'est effectivement que
l'arabie saoudite et répété il ya encore
quarante huit heures qu'elle s'en tenait
à l'accord opep plus c'est à dire la
garantie des prix du pétrole 10les entre
l'opep d'accord le producteur et la
russie et pour ajouter à ça on l'a
évoqué lundi sur ce plateau à lalinde et
on puis on l'a évoqué ce plateau la
semaine dernière le le larmes du blé ou
des céréales pour vladimir poutine qui
fait qu'un certain nombre de pays
dépendants de ces céréales sont dans une
forme de neutralité force et donc
effectivement ça renforce il dit je
pense que le il ya tout un travail
d'explication de ce conflit qui n'est
peut-être pas assez fait parce que il ya
trop de choses en même temps et j'étais
frappé qu'il ya 48 heures macky sall le
président sénégalais qui est président
de l'union africaine en ce moment à
l'annoncé qu'il allait à moscou et à
kiev et il trouvait ça très intéressant
parce que
il ya effectivement
besoin que que ces pays qui se sont
tenus à l'écart du conflit à y met les
mains dans le cambouis c'est à dire
comprendre ce qui s'y passe comprendre
qui sont les ukrainiens comprendre ce
que vladimir poutine est en train de
faire et en quoi ça les concerne parce
que si l'egypte demain à des émeutes de
la faim parce qu'il ya pas de blé
cessé parce que vladimir poutine a lancé
cette guerre au mois de janvier donc
c'est dit c'est on peut pas pour elle
expliqué injustement à l'africa au monde
entier qui pourrait être le porte parole
de cette guerre ou en tout cas le
pédagogue je pense que ce qui est est un
des éléments clés et il vient de
seulement macky sall a révélé que l ess
qui avait demandé à s'adresser à tous
les chefs d'état de l'union africaine
est donc le ce voyage est destiné à le
préparer parce que c'est c'est un
élément qui est totalement périphérie
par rapport à ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et même par rapport à ce que
nous vivons nous les sanctions etc mais
c'est un élément extrêmement important
de compréhension par une partie non
négligeable du monde de des enjeux de
cette guerre je voudrais qu'on compte
termine sur ses conséquences
géopolitiques géostratégiques du conflit
l'ukrainienne vous avez évoqué la
question de la militarisation il ya le
come back des des états unis quand même
on va donner quelques chiffres cent
mille soldats déployés dans les pays
baltes pologne roumanie des sanctions
économiques inédites une aide de près de
15 milliards de dollars déjà débloquée
et puis les 40 milliards de dollars qui
ont été votées par le congrès américain
on voit d'armes lourdes et offensive
christian makarian c'est d'une certaine
façon le retour de l'amérique
interventionniste quand même auquel on
assiste même s'il n'y a pas de soldats
sur le sol ukrainien oui on a une
question vient tout de suite à l'esprit
et si c'était donald trump le président
est là tout de suite le trouble
s'installe dans l'état dans les esprits
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il aurait fait
cet investissement là donc je crois
qu'il faut poser la question comme ça
joe biden avait promis contre donald up
et pour le battre une amérique plus
morale en revenant sur ses valeurs etc
du coup on est passé dans une forme de
manichéisme un petit peu à l'américaine
classique dire qu'on a l'impression que
certains combattent pour le bien contre
le mal monsieur lloyd austin qui est
secrétaire à la défense a dit une phrase
quand même terrible nous voulons voir la
russie suffisamment affaibli pour ne
plus faire des choses telles que celles
qui donnent qu'elle a commise en ukraine
nous voulons voir là
suffisamment affaibli bon ça a été
démenti comme d'habitude par la maison
blanche quelques heures après mais enfin
il l'a dit monsieur blinken a dit la
russie a commis une erreur stratégique
fatale ce sont des phrases quand même
qui démontre que l'état d'esprit
dominante des états unis c'est on va
mettre une raclée à la réussite durable
qui va nous installer dans une autre
phase de l'histoire peut-être on va voir
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que les montants je rappelle que les
états unis dépensent plus de
750 milliards de dollars annuels pour la
défense c'est assure passable inégalable
la chine en faisant des efforts
considérables arrive mais c'est
considérable déjà arrive au tiers de
cette dépasse et la chine est elle même
déjà quatre fois au dessus d'un dépenses
de la russie la russie c'est moins de 70
milliards de dollars c'est un tir il ya
un écart de 1 à 10 entre la la dépense
et la recherche américaine en matière
d'armements et et la russie quant à
l'europe la seule d'américains nous
incitait le civet le chiffre thomas de
40 milliards 6 et 15 milliards il ya 20
milliards seulement d'armement 20
milliard d'armement c'est exactement à
quelques mots quelques poussières près
la moitié du budget national de la
défense de la france qui est la nation
qui dispose de la force armée la plus
crédible ce continent européen ça vous
donne une idée de tout ce qui va arriver
dans les mois et les années qui viennent
et une dernière question et cette
dissémination d'armes une fois le
conflit n'ont pas arrêté puisque je
crois que cette guerre va énormément
durée mais ces âmes risque de se
disséminer donc on arrive dans un
univers plus périlleux qui nous oblige
nous européens à réarmer merci si c'est
l'heure du flash d'info consacré à
l'ukraine en ukrainien jonathan du prix
et vous pouvez nous nous rejoindre à
destination des réfugiés d'ukrainiens en
france c'est d'abord cette information
sur le plan diplomatique
alors le loyer le ministre français
chargé de l'europe il s'est dit
aujourd'hui convaincus que l'ukraine
ferait un jour partie de l'union
européenne
c'est en tout cas ce qui ressort des
échanges entre clément bonne et olga
stéphanie china vice-première ministre
c'était ce matin au quai d'orsay et
d'ailleurs vous le voyez sur ces images
clément boon a aussi ajouté qu'une
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'ue était
possible souhaitable mais qu'elle
prendrait du temps
mister france ils peuvent dans les os 6
0 pour clément de bonnes vous préconisez
d'orsay clément boute d'audace jetons
green day s
voilà et le premier ministre le ministre
français pardon a estimé à 10 ou 15 ans
la durée du processus d'adhésion
ukrainien a lui même si l'ukraine
pourrait peut-être trouvé un horizon
lointain et se rapprocher de l'europe
notamment via ce projet de communauté
politique européenne souhaitée par
emmanuel macron de ski ministre aux
signes propres ou de cette nature qui
navigation krajina la baisse constatée
en asie
monyela makoun bout destinées au gic
tiens et voilà on va écouter clément
bonne et je vous laisse traduire le
ministre était vide
voilà ce processus s'adresserait
évidemment à l'ukraine mais aussi à la
moldavie pourquoi pas la géorgie encore
les balkans
dans l'actualité jonathan il ya aussi ce
chiffre le nombre de réfugiés ukrainiens
qui sont arrivés en france depuis le
début de la guerre ou et thomas 85000
c'est le nombre d'ukrainiens réfugié en
france et ce trois mois jour pour jour
après l'invasion russe du pays et cette
donnée elle a été révélée aujourd'hui
par l'office français de l'immigration
et de l'intégration
mais il inquiète pc çitaku y ait
quelques green c'est bien qu'ils n'aient
je suis plutôt fan sénat min ch din
daeng
dira si la base est pour jouer pitrem
queue de l'appareil après tout quoi et
cascades est un suspect comme avis mais
n'alloue de nous écouter mais aussi
sur ces 85 mille personnes 8000 serait
actuellement hébergés en logement et le
reste dans des structures d'accueil ou
chez l'habitant au total le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés
de l'onu estime que 6 millions et demi
d'ukrainiens ont fui à l'étranger et
plus de la moitié sont actuellement
pologne ce kiss in de cette pièce et si
possible vicente cette nation et de
notre approche bagne de dire beaucoup
pour tout cas beaucoup j'ai tout fait
tout ce qui regarde ma routine comme aux
problèmes y avait comme nom commissaire
ou en australie je ne sais si ce pour
vous un millionnaire o'quinn si vous
voyez comme the crying vêtir pauvre n'a
pas bougé au point
enfin cette toute dernière information
informations pratiques que jonathan ça
concerne l'ouverture d'un compte
bancaire en france est tout à fait
thomas et c'est la banque de france 1
qui vient de publier plusieurs livrets
informatifs en ukrainien que vous voyez
ici à destination des réfugiés bien
qu'ils souhaiteraient tout simplement
ouvrir un compte bancaire
band fiona introuvable qui est capable
de la biguine six équipes ont retiré des
banques et là on
voit là et avoir un compte français 1
c'est une étape clé à la fois pour les
réfugiés qui sont ici au titre de la
protection temporaire accordée par la
france et qui voudraient pourquoi pas
accéder au marché du travail avoir un
logement un peu plus pérenne ou obtenir
certaines prestations sociales on en
parlait comme la location pour les
demandeurs d'asile et cela peut sans
doute simplifier un petit peu leur
parcours du combattant ici malgré tout
ce qui s'est passé
autrement sinon
merci beaucoup merci jonathan merci
reina pour d'avoir assuré la traduction
comme chaque semaine sur sur ce plateau
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce sens
public